thor 366 vidéo il fallait que ça arrive
je suis tombé malade
mercredi dernier j'ai joué mon spectacle
à bellou stone dans un château il
faisait froid
je pense que je suis tombé malade à bord
alors hier comme j'avais une vidéo
d'avant celle avec la carlo j'y joue les
mises en ligne mais aujourd'hui il faut
que je tourne parce que je le prendrai
vraiment mal si je ratais le défi d'une
vidéo par jour pendant un an juste parce
que je suis ma balle mais j'étais bien
passer au travers cette année bref salut
aujourd'hui danseurs sujet je vous
propose que l'on s'attarde sur l'origine
d'un nom et pas n'importe quel nom
puisqu'il s'agit de celui de sherlock
holmes prenez votre loupe abîmer votre
pipe et c'est parti
sherlock holmes est donc capable d'
incroyable déductions en regardant une
personne un objet en prenant en compte
le contexte et en établissant ses
hypothèses l'approchent cas ce
personnage de fiction est toujours
rationnels depuis sa création en roman
jusqu'à toutes les adaptations récente
qui a pu avoir en filmant en terme de
série ce personnage fictif donc a été
conçue pensée est née dans l'esprit de
sir arthur conan doyle
il a d'ailleurs confessé dans un
interview avoir eu l'idée en 1886 alors
qu'il avait encore son cabinet de
médecine à plymouth
il ya vraiment trois choses qui sont
intéressantes à savoir à propos de
charles comme c'est l'origine de
sherlock holmes de son nom et de son
prénom l'origine aussi du personnage en
lui-même tel qu'il a été décrit et le
rapport qu'avait rationnelle sir arthur
conan doyle ou plutôt même à
l'irrationnel pour le prénom de sherlock
conan doyle avait expliqué qu'il a gardé
toute sa vie le carnet où il avait fait
de son brainstorming pour trouver le
prénom il voulait pas que le prénom
représente une caractéristique du
personnage en lui-même dont il voulait
pas d'un monsieur futé ou d'un monsieur
rusé qui aurait donné mister sharks par
exemple en anglais alors il se
positionne sur le prénom sherrington
d'abord puis sherrington il enlève le g
mais il trouve que la prononciation est
pas très fluide puis s'est rappelé qu'au
cours de sa vie il avait croisé un
joueur de criquet qui s'appelait
sherlock
ça ressemblait un peu mais c'était plus
facile à prononcer et ce prénom était
aussi l'auteur d'un des livres de
médecine qu'il avait chez lui et celui
d'un célèbre violoniste qui l'apprécié
particulièrement donc bon c'était acté
ce sera charles et pour le nom de
famille
holmes il avait prévu au départ que ce
soit up qui signifie espoir en anglais
c'était surtout le nom d'un baleinier
sur lequel il avait servi en 1881 trois
mois à partir de 80 parce que je crois
qu'il est resté un nom dessus
attention il faudrait vérifier cette
information je suis pas sûr il servait à
bord en tant que chirurgien sur le
bateau pendant une chasse à la baleine
néanmoins il se refuse encore à donner
comme nom de famille quelque chose qui
est une caractéristique précise de qui
sera le personnage est comme ça veut
dire espoir et un peu de confusion alors
il porte son choix sur quelqu'un qui
existe qui est un auteur de romans de
posy et principalement à la base de
livres de médecine c'est quelqu'un dont
il est fan c'est oliver wendell holmes
c'est comme ça qu'il a trouvé le nom et
le prénom de sherlock holmes mais ce qui
est encore plus intéressant c'est que
personnage en lui-même qui il est ni
plus qu'inspiré d'une autre personne qui
s'appelle joseph bell professeur
d'anatomie d'edimbourg qui enseigne à
condom quand il était à l'université ils
adorent et observer les gens leurs
vêtements leur malheur
caractéristique peut-être leur accent
quand il parlait pour essayer de déduire
un maximum de choses par la logique
durant les cours qui donnait il
encouragé ses élèves à faire comme lui
avec leur propre passion il prenait
beaucoup de plaisir a bluffé les gens
aient à faire des révélations sur les
personnes avant même qu'il n'ait
commencé à engager la conversation
le plus amusant avec conan doyle qui est
l'auteur qui a créé le personnage de
fiction qui est sûrement le plus
rationnel et le plus amoureux de
l'esprit logique et de la déduction en
général et bien c'est aussi quelqu'un
qui avait la plus grande croyances
auprès des médiums et dans la rue
spiritualité en général conan doyle
était convaincu qu'il y avait une vie
après la mort il a écrit de nombreux
livres à ce sujet et sur le paranormal
il était d'ailleurs au fil des années
devenu très ami avec harry houdini le
célèbre magicien houdini à l'époque
cherchait à rentrer en contact avec sa
femme qui était décédé on pourra en
reparler de ça si vous les mettez le
mois dans les commentaires je pourrais
faire un sujet là dessus parce que c'est
assez passionnant mais houdini qui était
déçu de n'avoir rencontré en fait que
des charlatans s'était mis dans une
quête de les discréditer tous malgré ça
et c'est là où c'est drôle la force de
la conviction
conan doyle jeu rocade car la caméra est
tombé je disais donc malgré ça et c'est
là on peut voir la force des convictions
conan doyle et est persuadé qu harry
houdini avait de réels pouvoirs des
pouvoirs de médium des pouvoirs magiques
il l'a d'ailleurs écrit noir sur blanc
dans un de ses livres qui s'appelle le
bord de l'inconnu et houdini n'a jamais
réussi à le convaincre que ce qui
faisait lui n'étaient que des tours de
magie avec des trucages de magicien
j'espère que ce qu'on en sait des
origines de ce personnage de sherlock
holmes vous aura plu c'est mon
personnage de fiction préféré et de loin
si c'est le cas n'oubliez pas de laisser
un pouce en l'air n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner avant de partir puisque le
mental boxe et une vidéo par jour
pendant un an du 1er janvier au 31
décembre donc rendez vous demain à 17
heures oui ce coup ci j'ai bon ben ça
fait deux jours que je me trompe et dans
les heures demain à 17h ciao